I'm excited to announce that we've got
brand new merch up on the theovan
store.com they got the Rat King Racing
over there if you like race and getting
speed and tickets or doing
um IndyCar NASCAR hell if you like to
damn ticker tickle your Uber Uber Uber
Uber driver if you like to tickle him
damn
I need to tickle my throat and get these
dang words out you know
but if you like to do all that head on
over there theovanstore.com and we got
that racing gear for you
today's guest is returning to the show
for a second time
um he is his life has changed a lot
since then
when I met him he was you know living
out of a trunk or something I'm not a
trump I don't know where he was living I
don't know he was alive
but he's probably
who knows he could have been selling
hair
um he's a good man I'll say that and he
hosts one of the most popular and
um and unique shows in the universe
Sunday conversations and
um and he's part of Barstool Sports and
he is he is one of a kind I'm grateful
to have him back uh now that his life
has just really expanded so much uh he's
my friend and I say that honestly Mr
Caleb Presley
me
I'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
Kayla Presley
I know
the ovonne
Caleb Presley
um man thanks for coming back do you
know what you this is your second time
coming on yes it is I kind of finagled
myself on the first time but yeah it
seems to be back for real it was awesome
man it was cool yeah I know uh the
producer at the time Nick Davis was like
a huge fan of yours yeah he was like
um
he was like you got this guy you got it
this guy yeah he's my road dog yeah
what's he doing now and he was right
he's doing well he's still producing
um podcasts and doing some of his own
stuff and betting online yeah and
spending time with his grandmother yeah
well as you sure they're probably
betting together oh yeah I think
actually I did one of the picks he sent
me I did see I think some slots in the
back so
um yeah what's going on man oh dude I'm
your neighbor yeah that's true for a
while you moved out here to Nashville
how's that been for you it's been good
so far I haven't been here that much
uh Falls like the busiest time of year
for me so I'm traveling but uh I've
liked it so far it's a lot of like they
try to I notice if you go downtown you
see a lot of fat stuffed in the boots
dude I told you that I was like this is
the it's way fatter than I thought I was
gonna be yeah and I mean it's all love
but that's there's a lot of there's a
lot of fats out here oh it there is and
most on the female side and I'm not even
saying not even looking from a sexual
perspective yeah they're just a lot of
girls who are
they're on Broadway oh yeah and they're
fat big baby they're thick now they're
thick yeah they change it man but it
because it is you know they definitely
fat has become more designer yeah I
think the Kardashians did that because
they had that kind of desert fat that
ass did you see the story that uh Kim
apparently like cut her ass off it's off
now wow and did they do anything with
the meat or whatever I think they had to
if I don't know what they did with it
what would you have done with it oh I'm
sure she gave it to blacks man if you've
seen like a lot of her history you know
yeah she does a lot of stuff for like
the African-American community and you
think they would reappropriate or just
eat it I don't know dude look I'll tell
you this if I got a half pound of uh
dashian ass in the mail bro yeah
I might sear it but I might not cook the
whole thing yeah I mean look I'm leaving
the middle rare
and I think I'm eating it alone yeah
yeah
you might have to dude honestly
candlelight dinner and
and you're gonna be hungry afterwards
too for dessert it's gonna be a hard
meal to follow oh that's gonna be a hard
little follow-up yeah I don't know
that's crazy I didn't know that they
were cutting off their butt yeah I think
it's I I mean I don't know if that's
true I saw it online yeah so
could be true dude it probably Biden's
doing it or whatever
um
yeah man you're here so what has that
been like like were you kind of like
what was kind of the the idea was coming
to Nashville what was like was there
like a big goal behind it or you just
well I was in so I lived in New York for
like five or six years because that's
what really The Barstow headquarters is
oh yeah and I'm still with bar so I
don't some people don't know if I am or
not but I am and um just because my show
is just so I'm not at the headquarters
so they have like a headquarters in the
in New York City where everyone goes in
every yeah I've been in there and a lot
and actually like a lot of the people
who work for Barcelona not there anymore
but I was always there and I just left
and people were like some people were
like what are you gone yeah people don't
know sometimes but anyway so I moved to
Florida
uh covet in New York City was ass oh
dude they were like they got way too
serious about it well also it's they
didn't drop they they didn't drop the
prices oh damn you know if you feel like
you're being really serious about it be
like you you give relief to some of your
people yeah you think you discount
people a little bit you know you know it
could have just been my landlord though
right that's true but anyway so I got
out I got out of New York it was just
kind of crazy and I was I was playing
golf a lot at the time I was like and I
dedicated my life to be a professional
golfer I remember that yeah and uh
anyway so I moved to Florida to pursue
that and I was serious about it as
serious as you could possibly be and
what did that entail like would you get
up in the morning and do golf yeah so
this is my whole thing with so during
covet I played golf for the very first
time okay because my whole life and it's
just kind of like you I've tried to
convince you to come play with me and
this is kind of the same thing you say
to me is like I would tell my friends I
don't want to hold you guys up yeah like
I don't mind coming like I don't have
any of my own clubs you have to buy my
balls tell me the rules I'm gonna stink
and it's gonna just ruin y'all's time
and that's not what I'm trying to do
yeah I don't want to be like looking for
you like waving from far away or if you
guys are having a fun time I don't want
you to
be like oh Caleb's still hitting or
whatever it is yeah but then finally
during Kobe there's no other options so
then I was like I guess they're like
kill come on what else are we gonna do
and so I played one time and I was
hooked immediately I was like this is
the best sport I've ever played my life
and I grew up playing sports football
basketball whatever yeah I was like this
is my favorite sport I've ever played
and then I was like looking around I was
like looking into it I was like these
guys are professional golfers are not
even that good of athletes uh-uh they
don't seem to be yeah there's a lot of
fats yeah a lot of fats I seen a couple
of them on Broadway oh dude I saw John
Bailey one night overdose on I don't
even know what it was Gin I think and
get carried out of a ball like get
carried out of a restaurant yeah not
even a bar
what restaurant was it
um it was 12 30 love downtown yeah
now look it's a great establishment it's
the kind of place where you could have
so much fun that you got to have it you
know they got to send an ambulance for
you because you know your whole vibe is
on fire but yeah they had it had some
dudes carrying them out
and one dude like fire like firemen
carried him you know I keep on waiting
for this to like have like a joke in it
but so far it seems seems pretty
accurate to what happened yeah and I I
just turned it on one of those people
it's just kind of like video on them I
didn't put it up because it felt kind of
embarrassing but yeah and but the crazy
thing was I saw it happen again Where
They Carried John Daly out of a ball out
of a place I mean it probably happens to
him pretty often yeah I think he's
definitely become kind of like the cat
like he's like the bad you know he's the
bag of clubs dude can you imagine how to
carry him oh I can't even imagine either
catty him out dude so one time
one time I was in uh this is like early
on in my career and I was trying to
figure out what I was doing like you
know I was working at barcel trying to
figure out what kind of content I was
making or like what where was my Lane so
I was just trying a bunch of different
stuff so one time I love John Gruden you
remember the Coach Johnson yeah uh you
were on an email chain with him weren't
you I was on an email team with him that
I should not have been on it yeah yeah
but anyway so I was like all right this
is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna this is
when he was not coaching he was just
doing his football show all right I was
like I'm gonna do a segment and in
hindsight and saying out loud it sounds
dumb and it was yeah I'm like I'm just
gonna find him I'm finding junker like
just find them and there was no like
there was no like find them and then I'm
gonna it was like I'm just gonna find
them and uh so anyways I was like doing
all this research talking people who
knew
and so replying to Bucks fans DMS yeah
so I was like
I was like I'm gonna find this guy
anyways I ended up in Tampa and they're
like he he is headquarters is in the
Hooters the original Hooters oh wow
like that's where he runs a show from
that's where he shoots his show
and so I was like all right so I went to
the original Hooters I was at the
restaurant it's in Tampa and I was
eating I was like you guys seen John
Gruden recently and they're like yeah
every day
I was like well where's his office it's
in here right they're like oh no no it's
incorporate I'm like and that's
corporate right across the street across
the parking lot wow so you're there huh
and did you wear something nice you just
wore just regular clothes yes wore
regular clothes wow that's cool early in
my career yeah yeah I wasn't even at the
closed stage of your career
and uh I walked across the street and I
went into the corporate office and I was
like I'm here to see Jon Gruden and by
the way corporate office of Hooters
and uh damn bro that's the corporate
office too of the world when you think
about it it's the corporate office of
every 11 and 12 and 13 and 14 and 15
year old boys I mean I still got my hat
on and this was I didn't even know we
were telling the story today
um but anyway so baby them tits boy
I also hosted the Hooters conference
this year or the the pageants we can
talk about that later but so I go in
there and I was like I want to see Jon
Gruden they just took me back like take
to his office yeah he wasn't there but
his assistant gave me a tour and it's
like what are you looking for him for
it's like oh I don't even know what I
said oh
who's here to see him you know
yeah so show me around the office this
is where they shoot this is where he
does this
and they're like this is uh John Daley's
room
and I was like
what do you mean John Daly's room and
they're like and they open it up it's a
you know like The Chronicles of Narnia
a wall that has a bunch of books and you
can push it open yeah it was literally
that you push it open and it was just a
very small room smaller than this room
and it had a mattress on the floor and
like a little putting thing and I guess
John Daly lives in there wow really
inside inside John Gruden's office
inside the Hooters headquarters
and he and they say he Parks his bus out
back and then whenever he just needs a
place to be outside his bus he goes in
there oh wow so he goes and stays in a
bus also yeah that's almost the most
homeless [ __ ] you can do I feel like
like live in Hooters and live in a like
being a bus but I guess if you love
living in a bus dang and so did it have
like a sink or anything in there yeah I
think it's probably just because people
get so I mean if you're trying to carry
him back yeah you know you want to walk
up those stairs onto the bus so
sometimes it's probably just easier if
it's a smaller person he's at the
restaurant with small people who's
eating Chinese or something yeah let's
take him right into the lay him on the
ground damn I can't believe that dude
see that's a good top secret way to go
about business a lot of businesses I
feel like think too much like let's put
the business in this big business you
know Applebee's yeah they're like oh
every time you go in you know whoever
you know everybody's doing Applebee's
bro but it'd be crazy as [ __ ] if you
look under like a a table or you move a
booth and there's like a Marathon gas
back in there so yeah there's just a big
computer John Gruden Gmail
damn dude I wonder if that's where he
was sending those wild emails from I
don't even really know what he said but
apparently was bad dude I got a wild
story like that so one time I went over
to there was some dudes man two white
guys one of them wasn't White
and we went over there and
um
it was about business right yeah so I go
over there and uh and I'm ready for
business or whatever and it was like a
business meeting so anyway they said hey
it was in like the Hollywood Hills
somewhere and like hey do you know this
is
um
Jared Leto's house right no way and I
was like really This Jared Leto's house
and um and so next thing you know
there's a bunk there's like a they're
like you want to see something cool and
I'm like yeah you know I'm here for
business yeah right now so they open up
like it looks like a huge refrigerator
door from like the Dharma Initiative or
something from Lost yeah right they open
it up and it's like a hallway from like
the 1930s or something
his house was part of the property was a
bunker like a war bunker that was like
built into like a hill
and we walk back in there bro it's like
walking back in time you're like in like
it was like a 19 like third 40 50s
hospital or something there's um there's
like a cafeteria and that was insane bro
there was like 70
000 square feet
of Bunker
and then like probably like a nice 4 000
square foot house you know like yeah but
the amount of Bunker that he had I can't
even imagine bro if you're just like I
got two questions one do you think
you're getting trouble for saying that
I don't know with who the military
yeah well I didn't even think about them
just with him and two what business
meeting was it I hope not
I don't think the military will care
what kind of business meeting were you
doing at Jared Leto's house uh I don't
remember it was like okay dude I've
heard some stories I'm not sure it was a
business meeting really I mean he wasn't
there oh really it was too other he had
a couple little land sharks there a
couple you know employees co-workers you
probably got to work your way up before
you can even meet him or see him well
years later I met him oh really yeah now
we're like you know buddies you know uh
like not friends but like you know like
text and say hey and I see him at the
UFC fights do you watch his movie
morbius I went to the premiere how was
it
foreign
I don't think those are my kind of
movies you know well me neither I didn't
see it for that reason it was I mean I'm
actually a huge fan of his but uh yeah I
didn't watch it um and I didn't like
bats you know we didn't have a lot of uh
I don't think we had a lot of bats
growing up around our area and so I
didn't really know anything about bats
and so I think a lot of it I was trying
to just figure out what bats get the
whole concept of it like what are they
yeah yeah why are they
yeah
yeah dude I'll tell you maybe you would
hate what
Batman oh yeah have you seen that did
the whole thing I don't want to spoil it
the whole thing's like bat Centric oh
is you probably get some more
explanation and Clarity on like what it
is but you really probably would not
like it at all
you know there's [ __ ] you can light it
on fire that's what I read somewhere the
bat
um droppings or whatever or you could
light it on fire
that's just a myth I don't know what if
you know I don't know if that could be
true yeah I don't know but anyway so
yeah but I wonder if John Gruden Works
in there that little bunker that would
have been crazy if he was in there dude
do you think they have a staff in there
I don't know man I mean I know he like
his band they do like some pretty wild
parties yeah bring up a 30 Seconds to
Mars party
I think it's called 30 seconds tomorrow
you just kind of hear stories but I mean
I don't know I've never met him and it
seems like kind of a different life than
definitely I live and probably you too
is what they're kind of doing
um he's very beautiful you almost he has
he kind of embodies like a woman man and
child in one
you almost don't know if you want to put
him on a school bus or like uh
you know or um
you know he seems like he's always in a
wedding kind of he kind of has that
right that makes sense yeah I don't know
why throws that I did make sense they do
some real fancy parties
um him and his brother he's from
Louisiana
dude there's nothing like just that
gives you the feel of a concert like
reading an article jpeg
now I've seen though I mean I've seen I
mean it's yeah they do some exotic well
he's like uh you know a cult leader and
stuff like that are excused of it and I
don't know if that's
I don't think it's bad yeah about
setting on the cues maybe is a harsh
word like he he's like
someone made a rumor and he was awesome
first of all if I'm a cult leader good
for me I feel like right yeah I hate how
they're always like oh this [ __ ] cult
leader you know or whoever you know or
like whoever it is Billy Graham or like
Mike Lindell or whoever these people are
you know like uh who the guy that did
the XFL you know all that [ __ ] but it's
like
if I'm a co-leader I'm [ __ ] let's do
it yeah what would you do for your cold
what would you have them do
or what do they need what do you someone
needs to do like once they're in how do
you maintain your membership I think sex
mostly yeah it's like it's like you
you're right on the same page as pretty
much everyone else I think I mean the
only reason you get into a cult I feel
like
is probably for some kind of light sex
you know
I don't know we had a guy one time on
here who beat
what's that does he has like a disease
or something where you can't talk
um
he had a stutter and he
he was in
um he was in that xmv cult yeah ex-iv
the one that they busted the guy really
yeah and then we did what happened with
his stutter it went away they cured it
though
so did it come back after or no he
didn't have him when I saw him really
you know it could have flared up later I
don't know but he uh I just if there's
enough people around you [ __ ] dude it
can heal diseases I think do you see
that story about have you been watching
House of dragons the new game I watched
the first one and I got I couldn't
understand what's going on so I'm gonna
start over
they said I mean I just read article is
like
they have a scene it was in a bottle
again no spoilers but there's a scene
where they're in a brothel and uh the
main actress was like they had extras in
there who met each other that day who
had the 69 for 14 hours on set that day
really
okay this is my question for you then
man if you're throwing out some real gas
out here uh would you rather be the
person on the top or on the bottom you
think bottom yeah yeah because you're
kind of relaxing yeah yeah
you're chilling yeah you could rest I
bet they made them switch like every
half hour but no because continuity
yeah you get deep into editing you find
out it had to stay exactly the same spot
yeah and probably doing the same thing
too oh it's not a joke dude they
probably had to literally because
they're doing the same shot over and
over and they have to have
they switch angles the people in the
back had to be doing the same thing so
if you're doing this and you you got to
the same speed
12 hours 69 is for children I think it's
hard as you the older you get it's
harder to do yeah
you know I've always thought that 69 is
more for chill not children but you know
what I'm saying like
of hate people who want to [ __ ] that or
whatever age as long as they're both
cool with it 18 yeah in Most states yeah
yeah
um dude oh dude I was on a I was on a we
shot a TV show one time and they had it
was like a there was this party scene
and the guy
who was uh
remember that song it was like climbing
the stairway to heaven
so we're there's a party at that there's
like a we shooting at that guy's house
right yeah I think I think it was that
guy and
um they had people like [ __ ] doing
sex at the party they hired him
right so they were supposed to be
in the background having fun just having
sex right
so we're just been doing this acting all
day this scene and stuff and finally it
gets on in the evening and those those
actors get there and they're just like
they just started
the guy like all right move over here
here [ __ ]
and balloons the last person some guy
was supposed to be blowing up balloons
so you're like okay one here yep [ __ ]
balloons
and these borders and the the one of
them have been like I just came from
[ __ ] somewhere else and I was like
damn
they just travel those types of people
just traveling that's their life you
know
do you think ebl would do that if you
had a I mean you're getting into acting
a little bit aren't you a little
thinking about it or yeah so do you
think that
you'd be able to do that you think you'd
be able to
no but would you what would you say if
they had that was a big part of your
script
I would say look man I'm gonna try
I'm not gonna make any promises and
I think we should have an alternate
ending to this scene yeah
because I just my whole life I've never
been a great
you know that's not been like I'm good
I'm good at say I'm good like
I'm good like the pre you know when the
guy walks to the ring yeah and the
music's playing dude and they're
checking him down in the big black guy
shows up and Pats him down or whatever
that's before foreplay yeah I'm good at
that
I'm good at [ __ ] let's you know let's
be ready yeah we ready I'm good at all
the intro music and everything it's just
once it starts I think sometimes it's
just too much
I don't know if it's the viscosity or
what it is and then some so but I'm yeah
I'm just not a distance Runner I'm more
of a shot put
laughs
yeah hey you know but I mean that that's
in the Olympics
and people can make careers off that
they're not I don't think it's good ones
yeah I think you probably have another
one as well that's true but still you're
lucky to have background on like a
Campbell's Chunky Soup bad I think a
year you might actually be in that scene
yeah that we were talking about earlier
yeah
welcome to ball fall they're calling it
that's what they're calling it because
fall winter
fall is just winners uh Sun this is weak
Sun
and when or that says coming and it goes
for your balls first you know that the
chilliness
so it's that time of year you got to
take care of your body
you gotta till the soil you got to make
sure that everything is uh escaped you
know what I'm talking about manscaped
join the over 6 million men God that's a
lot of men
worldwide who trusts manscaped by going
to manscape.com for 20 off
with free shipping with code Theo
I use manscape trim my body
I'll trim a whole little bag of hair a
little sandwich bag keep it in there put
a date on it
save it for Mom
whether you're brand new or already with
us at manscape you could use the crown
jewel of care for your family jewels the
Platinum package 4.0
shine your whole body up get your well
the lawnmower that body trimmer finally
you can get around that bag
and the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer get all the way in there
you can just deep in there damn trim
everything trim some old thoughts out of
your head
go to manscape.com get 20 off and free
shipping with the code t-h-e-o
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscaped.com when you use code Theo
manscaped clear out the leaves it's your
tree trunks time to shine and now a word
from our sponsor better help
you know
I remember
having so many problems it's all I had
all I had was problems over here a
problem they're a problem everywhere a
problem problem
all I had we did prop Stacks are
probably dang people couldn't get in the
door hey bud I can't get in there
there's all your problems in there
so that's why I had to get with better
help
better help
will help you create problem solving
tools
to eliminate some of those problems
create some Feng Shui in you
clear out them
all the luggage that you're carting
around
that's right better help it's convenient
accessible and affordable get matched
with a therapist after filling out a
brief survey and you can switch
therapists at any time
I've had uh I've had the benefit of
feeling less stressed more hopeful
and just an overall
um sense of possibility whereas I used
to just have a sense of uh stress and
Dread
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help.com Theo
what uh if you're you're sexual
finesse yeah if you had to put that in
an Olympic sport this is good yeah what
would yours be you think Olympic sport
wrestling
oh really
so it's a lot of like all like
chair out of the ring type of stuff both
people have their clothes on oh okay I'm
gonna try you know we're trying
dude I need a person has a boner
you hope
dude I remember one time we met this
Chinese kid and he'd never seen
wrestling before and then we told him it
was two guys trying to [ __ ] each other
he believed it yeah oh he believed it
but the whole time he's like he's just
like wondering why they couldn't both do
it you know he's like this seems so
crazy yeah still a winner yeah still a
winner man that's good wrestling is good
man
have you been doing Jiu Jitsu I saw
another story not to just keep giving
you uh pop culture stories but bring it
Tom Hardy the guy from Batman which you
wouldn't like yeah
um he won a Jiu-Jitsu competition he
entered into a jiu jitsu competition
under his name
and won it like a Brazilian Jitsu
competition damn huh
Tom Hardy
let's get an image of them get a JPEG of
them
bring up article let's read it oh wow
yeah look at that
and he won it huh
they said he was like uh preparing for
another for I guess oh he was in a movie
called The Rest the wrestler or
wrestlers and he uh won and he started
doing Jiu Jitsu for that and now he's
like a Blue Bell which I don't know
where that ranks
I haven't been I probably haven't been
to jiu jitsu in two months really but
I've just been training I've just been
trying to like I just kept getting hurt
so much yeah you know is it true what
everyone says about it just how it's
like
I mean if you watch podcasts from the
outside looking in which is kind of
where I feel like I am on the scale it
feels like almost all podcasters do Jiu
Jitsu
yeah why is that
I think I think probably well Rogan's
wrote Rogan got everybody into the Rogan
like merged like these two worlds right
right so that's where that like
symbiosis happened right and after that
you have everybody that kind of like you
start meeting all these guys and you're
like I want to be involved in this I
mean it seems cool oh it's good man I
did it for like my uh my senior project
in high school you went and did it yeah
you had to do something I think I did
MMA which is the same thing yeah that's
the same thing but I was a beginner MMA
so you had to start at Jiu Jitsu I think
right you started doing wrestling right
I think uh side control that's all I
remember mma's mixed martial arts yeah
so that's when they have uh kickboxing
and wrestling we didn't get into any of
the kickboxing yeah we didn't either
yeah we just stayed and wrestled but it
was it was good like it was it's kind of
weird because I would go when I was 18
so I was like there's some old dudes in
there
and you know they're big and they're
stronger than you and they're like real
sweaty well they're more sweaty I don't
know old guys are sweatier than young
guys and that part of it turned me off a
little bit but I did like the physical
component of
kind of just exerting yourself I was I
worked out you know Will Compton yeah I
mean I worked out with him today this
morning we work out sometimes in
Nashville he lives here and I don't have
like really a workout schedule at all
and so we'll do like a little kind of
easy workout and but this morning we did
like conditioning which I never do like
when I stopped playing football I was
like dude I'm never I'm never doing
anything athletic again really I was
like I'm never working out like this is
the stupidest thing like I've worked out
so hard for my whole life I'm never
working out again wow which and I did it
for a while and you start feeling real
bad you know so anyways I started doing
it I'm pretty much still feeling bad
yeah yeah you got to start feeling good
but we did conditioning this morning I
felt so much better after doing a
conditioning than just a lifting weights
and I asked will I was like why why do
you think it feels so much better to do
conditioning he's like well you just go
kind of like you can really exert
yourself hard as you can
I feel like that's kind of the same
thing with wrestling or you can't not
you can't like half-ass wrestling you
get your ass beat right so that's some
there's something to that it makes your
your brain feel better at least a little
yeah I think I think I know what you're
talking about but
um I like going sorry I didn't mean to
interrupt you I'm just saying I said all
that but then I realized about
conditioning I didn't try my hardest at
all yeah I was like oh like what if I'm
not trying yeah I wasn't I wasn't
condition sucks
it does suck dude
and then the only thing I realize I'm
conditioned before I get back home and
it's just me again you know yeah
yeah now you know I'm just alone again
dude I guess I'll make a taco you know
it's like gosh man yeah we always go get
a place in Nashville it's called Ethan
roast and we always go over there to get
like a little burrito afterwards oh yeah
and we've been we have a hard day of
conditioning we up our burritos to two
yeah so we only have one but like today
we had two burritos each bro all you
need is some boots now I'm telling you
dude this there's something about
Nashville baby where they just you know
they just wanna how much fat can I get
in this boot yeah how much fat can I get
in this boat do you do you like
Nashville like are you gonna stay here
for everything I here's one thing I
realized the people in Nashville are
awesome yeah awesome people a lot of
unique folks passing through town yes
um some of the best gas station hangs
yeah you I I go get coffee every morning
at a gas station oh bro you hit some of
these gas stations you need to go during
the owl hours bro when the [ __ ] owls
are out there's one there's they got two
owls land over there at night yeah and
uh there's a guy out there and he sees
the owls he tells you and then you owe
him money apparently right that's it
twice daily yeah yeah it is that twice
daily remember that tiger Mark so dude
over there bro that dude [ __ ] you
gotta pull up just before he sees those
owls if you want to [ __ ] do it on the
cheap but uh but I love that kind of
[ __ ] you know I love that
um I love that it kind of it's kind of
like
it still has some values to it
definitely it's a big town yes that's
what it feels like
um
so I feel like fortunate that I'm here
um I don't know if I'll stay here
forever I don't know yet I think if I
had me a wife or something maybe if I
got a wife
then I would consider staying somewhere
but until I get a wife dude I think I'm
just a rolling stone it is kind of hard
to decide like I'm just I'm the same way
as you in terms of
I could live anywhere right because my
work's on the road yeah like I for my
show for Sunday conversation I go to the
guest so as long as there's an airport I
could live anywhere but then you're like
I could live anywhere and then you got
to decide where you want to live and you
try a new city and you make a bunch of
friends and you're like
I'm gonna go try somewhere else where I
don't know anybody that's what I think
about this town uh and y'all damn yeah
because something some people they don't
even
they don't know you're some people don't
even know you're gone sometimes you know
people it's like
yeah it is hard to choose it's I I feel
sometimes I get so angry you can only
live in one place at one time
yeah that [ __ ] pisses me off but then
there's guys like Jimmy John who we both
know yeah who
like I talked to him this morning
because Houston had lunch with you yeah
we had lunch the other day yeah late
lunch to dinner
and
he literally is in a different city
every day yeah I was like dude how do
you do this like how do you
don't you ever want to just be at your
house and he said something like he said
something pretty cool I can't remember
what it was he was like
I'm not gonna let the old creep in or
something like that I'm this is not a
dry run like this is the the real deal
and I'm not I'm going until I can't go
yeah I get tired sometimes yeah I get
tired pretty easy man he had that guy
has like a million horsepower engine
that has a million horsepower feel
different yeah huge dog in them yeah two
dogs yeah man uh I think guys like that
would have been graded almost anything
they tried to do 100
000 some people are just like you meet
him you're like oh they'd be great at
whatever like no matter what they did
they would have figured it out little
Jimmy oh Jimmy John's nephew yes
now this young fellow is a
let's use a word to describe little
Jimmy it's big
hmm
[Music]
uh genius
he's he's like and for people who don't
know Jimmy John I mean I know you had
him on your show but like he's just I
had him on my show Too Your show
probably gave him a more insight to his
real personality but he uh he's just
like there's a here's an engine he's
he's super charismatic yeah pull up some
pictures of I don't know if we can get
him yeah but he's super he's super
charismatic he's super
likable immediately yeah he's super you
you feel he's accessible like he's not
like uh I mean he's obviously a
billionaire but he's not like some type
person that you feel like you can't talk
to him about anything you mean John Big
Jimmy John yeah yeah oh yeah dude and
then and but then also the same time
he is uh his attention to detail and how
smart he is and how much he he's
thoughtful about everything and I think
little Jimmy seems to be the kind of
same way which is kind of crazy because
how old was little Jimmy 13. I don't
know yeah he's got this camp and I don't
want to share too much of his details I
think he got his first kiss at the camp
he did he also motorboated himself for a
little while which I thought was
I mean uh look I I just yes I looked at
I saw the video and I didn't see it
because I wanted to see it I wanted to
make sure everybody was okay
but yeah he did he motorboated himself
cool kid but yeah uh but yeah that kid
yeah Little Jim it's I didn't know who
we were talking about little Jimmy is
like this like
Spitfire kind of he's kind of like a um
kind of young Rush Limbaugh of the
outdoors you know yes but Rush ate pills
and little Jimmy likes to hunt yes you
know he he is like and the reason I was
even talking about Big Jimmy's just
because he has all these qualities where
you like you said he'll be successful at
anything he tries yeah and you look at
Lil Jimmy and you're like this kid's
gonna either be the president United
States or he's going to be in jail yeah
yeah and it's and we told him that it's
like bro you got to choose you know like
you are you're a walking Legend already
but president or prison baby yeah that'd
be good for children president or prison
you get to interview the kid yeah or
just like a new line of Hillary Clinton
shirts
bro how crazy people forget that Bill
Clinton went to that he was University
of Arkansas how correct when you think
that they went to University of Arkansas
that's the craziest part for me I was
thinking this morning because I saw oh
because the the Monday night football
stuff with Peyton Manning and the
Manning family
how they have their whole thing with
like they got obviously Peyton Eli and
then the brother they got the young kid
who's coming up who's supposed to be the
best quarterback ever and then they got
the dad
they basically have their own like moth
they like their football Mafia yeah and
like you hear like Whispers and stories
like they are like the football Mafia
like they want your show shut down the
things shut down yeah or if they want
your show to go that thing goes yeah
yeah they got a lot of pull they've
always had that in New Orleans growing
up and they had Cooper the third brother
yeah and they always he was like he sold
insurance or something but he'd have a
commercial like I throw a policy over
this [ __ ] Mountain you know he'd have
like that kind of stuff you know you did
crash that car yeah yeah and his
family's like yeah you did yeah you did
man
um how was your whenever Aaron Rodgers
came through how was that was that
pretty what was something what was that
like he was the coolest
so we've probably had 30 or 40 guests on
my show he was
the the number one coolest dude that you
I didn't know what to think about I mean
I had you on the show but I had met you
a bunch of times before
he was the coolest guy that just didn't
know what I was gonna get he he could
not have been
he had this huge house
we did Lake Tahoe at this golf
tournament and
this is actually a good story so I have
like Bookers that's how I get my show
most of the time sometimes I'll know the
person or sometimes they'll hit me up or
I'll hit them up on like Instagram but
most of times it's a girl named a woman
named Kelly and uh another woman named
Peggy who from our booking department
who like put everything together so
Peggy books Aaron Rodgers on my show and
we get a list I don't know how it is for
your pod but it's like I get a list of
like would you be interested in these
people yes and I always just circle like
the best ones I don't even I just only
like Aaron Rodgers Tom Brady you know
and I never get any of them yeah or at
least I hadn't got any of them in the
past and then I got a message or an
email was like hey Aaron Rodger will do
your show and I was like no way really
it's like awesome there was gonna be too
much for men at the Lake Tahoe golf
tournament because she's on like a Greek
vacation or something
so we get to the tournament
and we're out there in Lake Tahoe I
don't know if you've been but it's a
hard place to get to you got a flight
Arena you gotta fly cross-country flight
Arena and then drive yeah yeah and so
we're out there it's not an easy place
to get to beautiful drive yeah it is
awesome poor place to go and then I hit
a Peggy and it was I mean I was bad
Reno's
growing
Reno's growing Reno's growing okay
and uh Reno is the only city I wouldn't
donate blood in dude honestly
because I felt bad about leaving it
there really
it's just yeah I just get like it's it's
just a lot of cigarette smoke it's
honestly the only thing I'd even think
about right now is think about how many
cigarettes have been smoked inside there
oh yeah
yeah we got stuck in a casino one night
there and they thought they found a body
behind some of the machines in there me
and um a wife you know not alive
they found a not a live guy behind some
of the machines did they even pick it up
yeah they got him out of there dude but
uh anyway go on your story sorry yeah so
you get up there it's tough to get there
it's tough to get there anyways and so
the say the shoot's on a Tuesday I don't
remember the shoot's on like a Tuesday
and it's Monday yeah and we're like what
time and where is this thing gonna
happen and then Peggy who's our Booker
is like hitting up his agent or whatever
and that we're gonna get back to you
he's doing this doing that and then
finally at night they're just like uh
we're gonna be honest with you we
haven't talked to Aaron in two months
the agent he doesn't answer any of our
calls
like Aaron Rodgers dang it's like you
guys are the Packers offensive
coordinator yeah right like he just
lives in his own existence like he just
is in this he's in this lane or this
like wave that he's just riding yeah and
that's kind of how you feel when you're
around him he's just kind of like he's
just on his own wavelength and he just
didn't talk to his agent for two months
so I'm out there I'm like what I'm gonna
do and actually shout out to big uh Pat
McAfee
that's awesome who worked at Barstool
and I was like Pat I hate to call him a
favor ever
and I would
I don't know how it could repay you
especially you've got what freaking 2
billion dollars now and all the access
in the world he's on every show but I
was like I really here's the situation
um Rogers agreed to do the show it's not
like
it's not like I'm asking you to ask
Rogers to do it he said he would do it
right but we just don't know where he's
at we can't locate him mystery and so
Pat talk to Rogers who he responded with
Pat and he was like show up at his house
this time tomorrow
so we get in there he the whole timer
with him he doesn't take his he doesn't
have shoes on the whole time yeah and
he's just like that's a move right there
he just in his I don't even know how to
explain he's just cool like he's
old-fashioned cool like you're around
him like this is a cool guy
and he was awesome on the interview and
then they give y'all sodas or anything
he had a full staff he had like a full
wow
like they made us drinks I we had went
out the night before and I think I was
like a little hungover and he was like
you need a drink I think he saw it in my
eyes like you want to drink and I was
like yeah I would take a drink so his
staff like made me like a margarita and
we did the interview it was awesome and
then we hung out meet him and Glennie
balls for like seven hours no yeah just
sitting on his porch talking
and I asked him every question I mean I
don't want to like
yeah yeah go too much into it but I
asked him every question that you could
think of asking why like off the Record
like off the Record what do you think
about this and he was super transparent
on us answered every question questions
you can't even believe would be answered
by anybody and he was just awesome dude
he was just
I kind of a man crush on him I guess I
don't know that's what that's what it's
sounding like I think he's a stud he's
just really a stud okay and is he
handsome does he seem Handsome when
you're around him I think he's
traditionally probably I think he's in
the upper tears of handsome but I think
I think he would probably say he's
he's Beyond he's Beyond he's like a
Beyond Burger for handsome Mike oh damn
he's a he but he's the real deal you
don't think about him being attractive
when you're looking when you're with him
you think about like this is
this is just like a I'm a football fan
too so like you know what he's done on
the field and like you know how good he
is or what he does yeah and then just so
how it could be that cool too and be on
your own lane he's super
authentic hmm
or that he is now I mean I don't know
how he used to be before the Ayahuasca
or before his whole like diff I mean I
think he's went through a lot of stuff
yeah right he seems like a journeyman he
seems like a man who's almost traveled
time now when I look at him yeah and he
probably has when you left him that day
did you feel like did you miss him yeah
it takes him right afterwards and I was
like we saw like a vaccination sign like
must be vaccinated I said I said you
can't come here you know yeah you just
text about like immunized bro yeah yeah
and gloomy balls feels the same way he's
uh Ball's gonna kill me for saying this
he's going Ball's background on his
phone him making any balls like this is
glenny's background on his phone I think
it's sweet man you know it's hard to
find good male figures out there in the
world these days
um especially athletes too because it's
been for a long time like
I mean you're a huge sports fan and so
am I it's like for pretty much our whole
lives athletes haven't been able to
while they're playing especially just
like say wild [ __ ] and be like really
good and have thought behind it I mean
here some guys say some wild [ __ ] yeah
but it's like they just didn't think
about it they accidentally said it right
but he's like I don't care
yeah and you know his his fan base is
every type of person every demographic
probably from multi-countries and he
just he just saying his truth and it's
kind of cool that's what's so cool yeah
yeah it seemed like he has like he's
like a six shooter like it wouldn't be
surprised if he pulled out a six shooter
same yeah I mean he is he just shot a
bunch of [ __ ] cool ass [ __ ] ideas
into the world no bullets I wonder what
he'll do after football oh
you know I got did he talk about
ayahuasca
um when I was with him it was before his
announcement that he had done it right
and he was like I'm about to say
something he's like he told me he's like
I'm about to do this uh announcement
it's going to be pretty controversial
and I'm an idiot and he was I was like
what what is it he's like well just that
I've been using a little plant medicine
and I was like I was like
I was like I was like we all know
I told him I was like dude everyone
knows that you've [ __ ] taken
ayahuasca
he's like you think I was like everyone
knows dude trust me it's like they won't
even make a blip on the news
and he says it was like every news story
I was like dude no one cares everyone
knows don't worry about it yeah
yeah I got actually because Aubry uh uh
Aubry Marcus invited me to go I was
supposed to go on that trip when they
went and you didn't go I had a show book
somewhere [ __ ] it was in I think Tulsa
and it had been sold out for like four
months I just felt like it I couldn't
I mean I could have maybe sent a mass
email to those people
it said like hey guys I'm thinking about
doing this you know I don't know but if
if like 50 of them said no we wanted to
see the show I probably would have done
this dude I honestly if you want to live
stream you and Aaron do an Ayahuasca
they've probably been okay yeah I'll get
a sold tickets to that dang yeah man but
he was I mean I I don't know if I
butchered talking about it but he is as
cool of a guys I've ever met
in in any Walk of Life is very very cool
to be around
no I think it's interesting man because
you always kind of like he's
he seems a little bit like he doesn't
seem like a company man that's what I
like about him no I could see how he'd
be frustrated to play with or definitely
to coach yeah you would but at this
point in his career you kind of Coach a
rattler you don't want to coach him a
smart one yeah who's probably better at
being a rattler than you are yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't understand how
any good quarterback has a quarterback
coach who was not a good quarterback
most of them here in play ever
there's a lot of the best but a lot of
the best coaches didn't play football at
all
I want to say a lot of them there's a
quite a like trying to think the guy's
name who is at the Georgia Tech Paul
Johnson I think who ran that triple
option
and like no one could stop Georgia Tech
running a triple option he never even
played a down a football in his entire
life damn he's like wrote up some stuff
he just liked options like what tell me
what's what's Saban's football
background
I don't think he played anywhere can we
look that up
I mean Bill Belichick like what what was
Saban owned like a Subway or something
like this is crazy what
yeah Belichick I don't know he looked
like he probably worked at a factory
somewhere
oh he played at Kent State who didn't
play defensive back at Kent State
University upon his graduation in nine
one nine seven three he had intended to
pursue a career in Automotive Sales
until the Kent State head coach Don
James two names for one hired him as a
graduate assistant wow now he's Nick
Saban
that's a bad dude he could have been
Nick sedan
[Laughter]
Nick Saban sedans
could you imagine that's crazy I
wouldn't buy a car for him a million
years
I mean I know a lot of [ __ ]
Mississippi State fans wouldn't
would you what do you think I think that
you'd probably be pretty good in that
lane slinging Vehicles yeah
I don't know man
I don't know some of those dudes are
rich
yeah but you have to be the owner to be
rich I think otherwise you just end up
smoking and going to AAA meetings yeah
true but you know yeah that you end up
in the economy seek to Reno dude Reno
yeah God
oh I will tell you this we were there
one time huge snowstorm hit a bunch of
chicks like uh all our shows got
canceled we had to stay there for four
days yeah and two buses of like co-eds
like chicks for like one of their
sorority ski trip they couldn't go up
the mountain so they had to stay there
and they dropped them all literally me
and my buddy Jamie Lister were sitting
at the bar like man our life sucked
[ __ ] 250 women roll in that's a movie
what happened
sex bruh really yep
let's go pretty good uh I mean not
pretty brief sex you know yeah winter
sex some wrestling yeah
yeah I should have tagged somebody in
what's your out of all the out of all
the places you've been what's the what's
your favorite weird City like favorite
play like you wouldn't want to live
there probably but like I just love
going there
man I really wanted to get to spend a
little bit more time up in uh
Portland Maine
really yeah it's just it's like such a
surprise that it's there
because you think it's a lot of people
out there [ __ ] you know who've lost
their eyeballs and [ __ ] you know out
there people out there just you know a
lot of people that you know hate people
that go with a burning man but wish they
would watch Burning Man videos at home
as a family yeah you know like that kind
of [ __ ] you know but uh but dang it's
there's just something about it dude the
cold wind just [ __ ] it is cool I like
it too pushes you out of the out of the
street one of the first things I did at
Barstow was like a travel show it was
like the Marshall travel show and
um didn't really take I don't know why
well I'm probably about to say why so we
were like we had episode in Portland
Oregon oh yeah so we went on shot a lot
of stuff there
but like we had some stuff planning we
went to like an RV sale and we got
kicked out of there we just didn't get
enough stuff for the whole episode and
we had a we liked our whole season of
episodes they're probably like 10
minutes a piece 15 minutes a piece but
this one probably had like five solid
minutes six solid minutes and so we just
took a
we took a flight to for we were in New
York like a quick flight to Portland
Maine we shot the rest episode and just
never said anything about it really you
watch the Portland episodes like half of
it's in Maine half of it's in Oregon
damn
we've just never mentioned it dang right
I just welcome aboard
dude that's wow one time you're at an
antifa thing and then you're eating a
lobster next minute
like wonder who this Lobster's voting
for yeah damn dude I wish I had black
lobsters those things would be [ __ ]
gang bangs yeah in the ocean dude if
they had some [ __ ] black lobsters
everybody deals with the Sunday scaries
you know what they are they're fears
moments where you're like dang Monday
Monday's lurking right around the corner
dang Michael Monday Myers over there
just eating candy and ready to chop
it's dangerous like that
that's a Sunday scary so there's oh [ __ ]
moments oh [ __ ]
got to do my homework gotta you know
deal you know look you see my children
see my step daddy whatever
get a job
well I don't relax well I'm telling you
that and with My Crazy Life it's hard to
shut off my brain I get Sunday scaries
all week
I'll be on Tuesday I'll be on Tuesday
talking about Sunday people say dang sit
down buddy have a cold have a cold water
and I don't sleep well so you know what
helps me or what could help you is
Sunday scaries CBD gummies
they can help you decompress clear your
mind and fall asleep so you can wake up
with a fully functioning human brain and
being you want to function well don't
you see somebody they're zombieing
around no shoes on
2022 it's all about self-loving and
taking better care of yourself
so whether you need to take the edge off
calm your racing Minds sleep better or
just chill Sunday scaries CBD gummies
are the answer we all have the right to
live scare free and let me save you a
little bit of coin over there with my
code
it is Theo for a 25 discount visit
sundayscaries.com and use my promo code
Theo for your discount that's Sunday
s-c-a-r-i-e-s.com
and use promo code Theo for 25 off
sundayscaries.com you know the NFL
action is in full swing over here at
DraftKings sports book
it's an official sports betting partner
of the NFL
they got touchdowns big plays little
plays everything and big wins
if you like to gamble if it's safe for
you and something you can do safely
uh DraftKings sports book is the place
new customers can bet just five dollars
on any NFL team and get two hundred
dollars in free bets if they do
if that's not enough everyone can boost
their winnings with DraftKings stepped
up same game parlays right now for every
leg you add to your parlay you can boost
your winnings up to 100
with payouts bigger than ever why bet on
football anywhere else some people are
betting on it crazy places Larry's bet
tank or whatever or Donny's double down
and you got to drive over there and
there's a some always they're always
burning stuff in the yard
Tighten Up download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now use promo code
t-h-e-o to get 200 in free bets if your
team wins when you place a five dollar
bet on any football game that's code
Theo only at DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details
um oh what I just see in the Netherlands
they had
did you see that thing brownies and
downies or whatever it was like brown
Cinder uh it was people that had Down
syndrome they Incorporated them and
they're running a um
a restaurant yeah
and this is it right here and people
were giving them hell on the internet
but you can go there and get you a good
brownie and meet up meet uh
you know one of God's Warlords you know
one of God's but you know I had such a
soft spot for like Heroes you know Down
syndrome if if I could when I have a kid
and that I mean obviously it's a
it's a
it's I mean they're like they don't have
an easy life and it's I don't think it's
super easy to
I don't not raise one but I think it's
like it it's hard down syndrome's hard
but they're so pure and so sweet I've
always said if there's gonna be like a
Down Syndrome kid I'll I'll take one
yeah I just love them I can see I could
see you doing it
um we had Chris nickichon and he's the
Down Syndrome guy who won the uh who
finished the Iron Man
and so that was like unbelievable
talking to him did he Flex On You oh no
he talked like he like likes CH he you
know he talks a lot about trying to get
with some hot blonde you know yeah
which I get you know I totally
understood that part of it yeah actually
that part I couldn't relate to was a lot
of like the physical one and that's what
I'm about to say
like his like achievements
yeah man he loves smoking hot Vines
that's what he's called he's like let's
get some smoking hot Bloods that's what
he kept saying over and over again man
but he that dude yeah he ran like 250
miles
um and like swam and he swam like as far
as you could let somebody swim you know
but uh pretty unbelievable that was
crazy but this place they have everybody
that works here has Down syndrome
so that's like and people were giving
them a problem but I think it's kind of
cool what could you give them a problem
about I think people are saying oh this
is wrong you know but I think it's like
at least now you can embrace it like
welcome to this place we have Down
syndrome because what I don't like is
when people pretend somebody doesn't
have Down syndrome yeah so many people
doing that well in our town growing up
they would do that a lot and be like
Eric has Down syndrome you know and like
no he doesn't you know like all right
well you know
like what
he's not doing great today you know his
service is just slow at least they're
doing it in Europe dude so he serves
slow anyways then he didn't get enough
rest you know
I mean but uh
pretty crazy I wonder what other
afflictions you could have and also have
like a cool
place you know
it oh establishment be incorporated yeah
yeah
like if they had what if there was this
where if there was a spot where every
every single person had had like herpes
I mean like everyone in here has genital
herpes
a hamburger
bro what about eggs and eczema yeah you
just go
the guy's like oh you want some assault
on that and he just rubs you know
dude what about
Pepsi no and Hep C
he's like hey
I'm gonna drink
you cry
I'm trying to think of some other good
ones we could have
dude this is great ideas
what are some good ones we could do man
I know sometimes I think about like just
those names like this the strip clubs
that serve food yeah tits and grits eggs
and legs yeah
you get like hangers and bangers
old saggy saggy saggy boobs no bras and
there's every potatoes oh
dude when I see a horrible tit it
[ __ ] makes my whole body hurt
it really does man oh same dude
sometimes and this is just me being
transparent honest thanks sometimes when
I I'll see someone who has like an
actual
I saw this is bad but this is just a
true story I saw a guy who he lost uh he
I don't know if he had a burn on his
face or he lost the arm maybe both but
I saw him I was at the movie theater and
I saw him and I did like that oh you
know and it's like
I don't know if he saw me or not but
it's it's a set there's something in us
that you're not supposed to
you recognize it fast I guess what I'm
trying to say it doesn't take your brain
long to see something like that to
recognize what's going on yeah yeah
we had a guy that tried to pretend he
had both arms for a while in our area
and that meant that everybody was going
crazy they noticed it yeah immediately
you don't want to say anything but you
thought it and then people thought they
were crazy you know
um and then yeah people trying to guess
that was a crazy part yeah people trying
to like
rip his arm off like just to see if it
was you know I don't like to what if
it's real
yeah just crazy man just ah people are
[ __ ] crazy man being oh they just had
that one what was the woman with the
huge breasts they had who was that
remember that
but I look I say more power to you
Netherlands
I I think it's like
you know I just
it's like
I think if people have down if they have
whatever let them get out there I'd love
to go to a place if I knew when I walked
in hey everybody here has herpes yeah so
they don't have to pretend that they
don't [ __ ] have herpes because I
think probably one of the worst things
about having some things is pretending
you don't have it you know
so I think that it would be great if
everybody could have a herpes in one
spot
or you know what I'm saying what you
know what I'm talking about they had a
lady big breast lady
um type that in
actually I think we have a Blocker on
this computer and I gotta get a new one
dude I've ended up masturbating the past
four days oh really because when we were
at that camp with Jimmy John you were on
a no masturbation uh I think you're like
35 days in or something I was doing good
and I was trying to convince you to jerk
it off I was like where you going
you're like dude why you keep wanting me
to jerk off
yeah when I started feeling bad about
myself I don't know why I wanted to jerk
off
yeah bro that was a weird Flex from you
bro
I will say that they had a lady with big
boobs who uh it was trans person who had
big boobs and the kids were loving it at
school
just
there you go
this lady has got those freaking
damn rib bonnets dude she's got some
bangers
there's a place for her at hangers and
bangers so bro there's no way you you
can you can't there's no way you can
park in front of those and not get a
ticket huh do you think there could be a
place where this is kind of a good look
at that one dude
what
what is she teaching
white face go up oh he probably is like
Lester Holt
he's a white dude I've always the long
thought that
yeah he has a very like um
you go
I mean that's right that's white faced
how can you have huge tits and have a
look on your face like you're looking at
huge tits
see this is how they're tricking people
and this is probably Biden doing this
yeah because they they're trying to get
more people to accept trans right and
just be more comfortable with it so you
send in somebody like this you send in
you know a real
and you use and then afterwards you just
take anybody yeah I mean this is trans
Mila Anderson right here dude I mean
they [ __ ] sent in they put the
biggest tits
but you don't even notice that they got
that wand baby
they got that yanker baby they got that
door knocker right under them
and look at those legs look like a man's
legs how many commercials do Jesus
Christ
god dude
bro I better bait I bet wait she teaches
a wood chopping class yes
of course she does there's a lot of wood
in there dog
but see this is how they're gonna get
everybody
by baiting with this kind of stuff
because you know it's just been kind of
like this weird like what's going on but
now
I mean this is crazy dude
I mean this is crazy
and look at that mask but what I don't
know and why doesn't she swim see if she
got in the pool and swam I would [ __ ]
be supportive of them
dude there's no way
that broad would make it off the dock
I mean never some dame God damn bro bro
if one of those bounce into the street a
kid would go get it dude those things
are [ __ ]
[ __ ]
these things are way worse off than
anybody that works at that brownie shop
I mean these are the craziest looking
things
I'm sorry man
I don't mean to go in all of that dude
who sells that shirt dude by the way
who sells clothing for this type of body
yeah who sells that shirt
Lulu melons dude
my god brother and I you know it's like
I don't even know at what point are you
not sexually attracted to a tit I feel
like there's a size yeah do you you know
what I'm talking about yeah there is
there's a size where a certain age man
is no like a seven-year-old guy like ah
[ __ ] drool all over that you know but
any decent man who doesn't drive a
[ __ ] Honda Civic and is over in his
under [ __ ] 50 is not gonna like this
yeah she blew past that dude
that whatever that threshold is she blew
past it yeah you think that she's
upgraded though do you think that she
went right to this she had like a cups
and went right to this and by the she I
mean he they right yeah they Sorry a
Canadian School Board is standing behind
a trans teacher who sparked protest
after turning up to class with clowness
giant clowness that seems rude
giant people say anything that they put
in quotations that's true
someone said she looked [ __ ]
to classes with [ __ ] jugs yeah
the blonde High School teacher went
viral after being filmed operating a cut
off saw in class
well that's who's building our [ __ ]
houses now that's why there's a back
order bro on everything because
this lady got her [ __ ]
she had caught in the saw
was it Oakville school teacher it
refused to identify the educator by
warning the wrong person had been named
an online report
say that again
uh they names they misidentified who it
was
oh my bad dude I'm sorry
uh we're sorry Miss Jackson yeah
we're sorry Professor Arnold yeah we
just had a typo some Disturbed peoples
have skipped classes held by the
Oakville industrial arts teacher who
began identifying as female last year
I mean dude what grade is it they're
gonna skip anyways yeah that's a great
point and I that and that's probably
what happens 10 or 12 people skipped you
know they don't want to come and then
and once you've been there twice it's
kind of like when you see the little
donkey at the fair yeah you know yeah
you don't need to go again
dude it yeah it's time yeah the little
Tom Thumb or whatever his name is I've
seen him
um
but wow that's wild but you know what I
think you're gonna have start to have a
lot of people that are going to be doing
this identification thing out of
not boredom but out of I want something
different in my life yeah I've been a
you know I'm not married or I or
whatever or I want to get out of my
marriage I'm going to say I'm in a woman
you know so then at least easy way I
think a lot of people are going to start
using this to get out of different
scenarios and why not it's not a bad
idea
not at all
your kid comes home you're like I'm not
your dad
I'm identifying as not your dad I'm
Miranda
you look like my dad
yeah look at these tits I just got in
the mail that's gonna change fast [ __ ]
up
those Dude Looks self-applied too yeah
yeah they do look bro those look like
they came with that adhesive bro
wow what else we got anything else in
the news going on
oh what is it
do not cook chicken and NyQuil well most
of us would recoil and horror from such
dangerous suggestions adolescents and
young adults continue to be susceptible
to social media dayers like these
of Nyquil chicken
what's the pro I mean I mean obviously
it's crazy but what's the problem with
it
I don't see an issue I mean you can take
NyQuil I've always thought that about
drinking salt water it's like I can eat
salt and drink water why can't I drink
salt water
yeah that's a good I can take NyQuil
before I go to bed I can eat chicken why
can't I have NyQuil chicken yeah maybe
they don't want the show maybe they
maybe it does something to the pan or
something
I don't know
this guy looks it looks like it's just
somebody in college
if you've ever been in college
day night dude what do you miss about
college man
did you love it or were you kind of like
I actually did so when I played football
right you played in North Carolina yeah
and what I missed about the most was
being around the dude like the guys and
just being around people because I went
and got a real job and I was like you're
just not around your friends
but then I made like a very concerted
effort to rejoin with friends and like
making that a huge priority and not even
like making a ton of new friends but
just like my friends who are my friends
like going out of my way to to make sure
I'm around them and and I feel like it's
got better because I did miss them
really bad yeah but like if I mean even
when I moved to Florida like I moved
where my friends were living I go the
last two weekends I bet I traveled to go
see friends oh wow just because I missed
that part of my life so bad yeah I
forget about how important that is I
noticed it just recently going in
training like with the same people every
day it's so fun
it's like ads it's like I'm I get to be
funny I get to joke around I'm like
normal person I'm not stuck in my head
yeah me me and will so I've been working
out with will it's this place called uh
boost fit in Nashville and it's it's a
it's just like a a big facility they
have a lot of athletic stuff in there
but there's also a school for hockey
kids who don't want to go to real school
and it's awesome they literally just
don't go to real school they do online
classes and they play hockey all day in
Nashville in Nashville wow and they have
every age so we'll go in there as we
work out and we'll like jump into the
sauna showers and then we're just
showering there's a bunch of middle
schoolers running around making fun of
each other's meets and stuff like that
why is he not getting naked you know so
we're just in there listening to it but
it's like man this is really this is
really what uh what being a guy's all
about oh my God
yeah dog look I've been through some
[ __ ] man we've all been through some
[ __ ] dude
that's crazy bro I never uh I don't know
some kid I remember tried to show me his
dick bro and I told him no yeah and I
was thankful for that man
um but kids are ruthless oh they don't
care like we're sitting there and we'll
be in the sauna and they'll all be like
waiting in line to get the showers and
stuff and it's ruthless yeah they're so
mean dude I'm like God he's getting
roasted right you want to step in be
like I'm not stepping it's dangerous
over there and you don't know the lingo
stepping down in the race bracket is way
scary dude terrible they're kids
nowadays it's like they're so on their
iPad they don't even notice if they get
molested I feel like well you know like
a lot of kids wouldn't even yeah
true
you know I don't know that's insane we
want to take that out dude well by the
time we get
but I mean I mean
like when I was young you weren't
looking at your iPad so like you know
you
were somebody's iPad
foreign
you noticed yeah but nowadays you can't
even get the kids attention probably
probably yeah
so depends on what they're looking at
probably yeah I think it's but it's like
I you know I was with my recent I was
with my family recently and there's some
children in our family and I don't think
that they saw me with their eyes for
more than two minutes yeah it's crazy
and it's kind of sad but it's also like
what are you gonna do yeah and it's
peaceful and it's peaceful yeah and then
as soon as they're they are hanging out
with you like where's your iPad dude
yeah you won't help you find it yeah the
second you get their attention you don't
want it yeah right
um what do you look at the NFL season
kicked off who are some teams what are
some of your teams you think what do you
think this kind of plays out as how do
you think Tom Brady does how do you
think this kind of rolls out for Brady
dude I don't know I've been seeing all
the stuff that's going on he doesn't
look good in terms of his just his face
well people are saying that I think he's
he thinks his face looks good he looks
leaner I just can't tell if he maybe has
had something done to his face or if he
just looks leaner I think I think if
you're
married to a model yeah the stuff that
you all talk about your house she's
always talking about cosmetic stuff and
it's probably just easy to fall into
that lifestyle of always trying to
improve your looks yeah
um but do you see what happened with
Brett Favre oh yeah he got caught up on
that money they bought a gym for
somebody yeah it's not good
but in terms of NFL the entry question
dude I I'm
I think the bills are a wagon I know
like who's doing anything to the bills I
don't I couldn't imagine anyone
but yeah I can't imagine I mean I don't
know if anybody in their division I mean
maybe if Miami shows up and shows out
one game well my like my best friend
from college is Mitch trubisky who's a
right starting quarterback for the
Steelers he was on your show too he's on
Sunday conversations yep and he's a
great guy awesome dude and you know they
drafted Kenny Pickett number one or for
their first pick so anytime you take a
quarterback first round that's your guy
right it's just a pay differential like
they're paying him more than they're
paying Mitch and so you kind of if
you're him I mean he's in the toughest
spot ever where it's like
on paper Kenny pick is going to be the
starter of their franchise and like
their franchise quarterback unless
that's what they want to happen but he
has to like step in for a time being
hopefully it's a full season or you know
he's a two-year contract two seasons
but just always having that weight over
your shoulder and he doesn't say that
there's a way in the shoulder but like
you know that you don't have that you
don't have that room for error yeah and
so I thought he's been playing like he
played last night I don't know when this
comes out he played last night against
the uh
against the old rounds and he like
played pretty good like they lost like
he looked good like he looked like an
NFL quarterback he looked like he
belonged on the field but he had the
pressure on some of those guys I can't
imagine a lot of that's a high pressure
situation
oh all of it is but then I also always
think like I tell him too it's like dude
you get they get paid for that pressure
like it's not like you're just a high
school quarterback and maybe you know
Friday Night Lights and it's like you
have all the pressure then you just go
home and whatever get on your iPad and
try not to feel it whatever you know but
uh you know he gets he he gets paid for
the pressure but that's a tough spot to
be in and that's so I root for him
really hard I have a bunch of other
friends who are on different teams that
play with the Carolina or guys I've met
throughout so I kind of root for players
I grew up a Panthers fan hmm But you
know our roof kind of for players now in
the in the pros so then who do you think
you see so obviously out of the AFC you
see Buffalo they're gonna have to have
some massive injuries
right it's not gonna be like one injury
he's not gonna take them out no unless
it's Allen which I'm not I don't want to
talk about that but I don't even he's
that dude is a he's a he's a dog though
he's a dog but they got they have
literally every single thing they have
great weapons he's amazing they have a
great defense Von Miller somehow dude
I'm a Panthers fan I told you Von Miller
single-handedly beat the Panthers like
10 years ago in the Super Bowl by
himself
usually the MVP of the Super Bowl like
25 years ago and he's somehow still like
wrecking every play yeah I can't believe
they ended up getting him that's crazy
man yeah for them yeah they're sick man
uh dude one night I went out here
somewhere and it um was with Josh Allen
and Dawson Knox right and it was so
funny they've both been drinking and so
they they made a bet with each other and
they were like uh I bet you won't name
your kid Fort Knox right that's that's
what one of them but the other one and
he goes I bet you won't name your son
wrench allen right so
they're like let's each bet a thousand
dollars you know I was like now I was
like Dawson you gotta bet you you have
to get him to bet more because he gets
paid more it's not fair you have to be
comparable and he's like so then Josh is
like all right I'll bet three thousand
right so I'm like well then Dawson just
made 2 000 bucks because neither one of
y'all gonna name your [ __ ] kid back
bro
[Laughter]
that's a good bet though yeah I mean it
was a good bet but it's like neither one
of them's gonna follow through so he
just made two grand I made that dude
[ __ ] two thousand dollars he honestly
owes you at least what he does
100 yeah probably 200 I would say 250
probably but they were arguing about it
as I walked off I heard them kind of
[ __ ] did you hang out with George
Kittle here I know he lives here no his
sister
um taught me yoga for a while Emma
Kettle really yeah do you like yoga I do
like it man I do like it sometimes I
just want I wish four people would just
pull off just completely pull my body
apart and run away with them
because I feel like almost once the four
forces combined it's just a bad deal you
know
you like it man you're already pretty
tall though see if you guys are gifted
with length you don't have to deal with
what we got to deal with in terms of
what just being you're always around
yourself when you're smaller yeah you
know it's so quick I Touch Myself yeah I
had a
uh bobon you know it's like tossful guy
in the NBA oh he played for the Mavs
he's got trades of the Rockets bull Bowl
uh similar okay but his name's bobon
bobon yeah he's like the new version
basically and uh I asked him I was like
dude and this is we haven't put this out
yet I was like
when you get like how long does it take
you to get a boner did they get that
signal down to your dick you get horny
in like 25 minutes later yeah you got
bad sci-fi
[ __ ] ain't going up dog
I wouldn't want to be I mean I think
that I think I mean you probably got
pretty good Heights yeah well I like uh
you know I I do get admirable of your
height well I'm six one I went to I
moved to Florida and I had to get a new
ID and I always said I was six two when
I was playing football oh yeah because
you always go an inch an inch more but
then uh once I finally submitted I'm
like I'm six one that's what it what it
is so I go to the DMV and I had covet I
think by the time I went to DMV I didn't
know but it turned out later
so by the way you see what the xanthus
did I don't know we already talked about
it the other day on here it's so awesome
hilarious but so cool
I read somewhere that rich people were
showing up to pet the [ __ ] people and
[ __ ]
but I went to the DMV and I was like
she's like how tall are you I said six
one and just somebody gave me my ID
print yeah they print it out right there
it says six three uh oh really I said
six three she said
kind of like gives a [ __ ] dude you can
take it or not I'm gonna get it back
it'll be five nine
it's like welcome to Florida this [ __ ]
is over there just changing people's
lives
oh dude in Arizona you only have to get
a driver's license every four you'll
need to get your driver's license
renewed every 40 years can you believe
that
stray roads yes
I mean that's true but I think just for
ID purposes every 40 years you show
somebody your idea if it's 40 years ago
yeah that's true I guess it is nice
because then people just have to take
your word for it
um but no I thought that migrant stuff
was hilarious dude people just shipping
migrants around we had a border patrol
guy on and he said the borders insane I
listened to the episode he said people
are coming across he's like he said and
it's not just like people like Mexican
people said it's all types of people
just wandering over like people with
briefcases to say bomb on the side of
them just like crazy [ __ ] man
and he said it's just he just said it's
unbelievable and they don't prosecute
him so they just it's basically Red
Rover they just peace
so that's pretty wild man I do like to
see I just like to see him mix it up I
like how the Santa's kind of mixing it
up yeah mixing it up just busting those
people yeah it's like and those people
get to see the country yeah you know
people like they're using them as pawns
like they just ran across a stream like
[ __ ] 50 miles sometimes they get
there even further sometimes so I think
a nice bus or anything yeah they deserve
a meal at least I'm sure they're feeding
them too yeah you know but yeah somebody
said that they some lady dropped off
like 200 cases of Perrier at the [ __ ]
for these people like what foreign
that's crazy lady
[Laughter]
oh dude I think it's gonna start getting
weird out there the weirdest [ __ ] gets
man the first people that are going down
are the rich man you think so oh in a
heartbeat dude are you are you in
trouble no no I'll never be [ __ ] Rich
how how uh [ __ ] that there's bugs in
here right now
it really is
no dude I think uh no I mean like people
are like Jimmy well yeah maybe but since
he made sandwiches he may have a [ __ ]
he he might have that that yeah his hand
he may have been in with the working
class I think there's a certain level of
Rich that's probably in trouble yeah but
it's not Jimmy and it ain't you it's
between yeah yeah
yeah I don't know who it is man but the
[ __ ] gets dicey I could just see it
because everybody wants to throw
something through a [ __ ] rich
person's [ __ ] window
you've done that before huh have you
done it
my brother did it and I watched him and
did it did he feel good after oh it felt
good for you or for him both he was
going through it some [ __ ] at the time I
don't know if he loved it
you could enjoy it but I was right there
to enjoy it for him dude I've thought
about it I've no doubt I've replayed it
in my head probably a thousand times
dude there's some rich people here in
Nashville yeah there are sometimes I
drove out here there's some house some
some really nice houses and there's a
lot of like famous people who live here
too that you don't know about yeah like
this you would never know they lived
here Mookie Blaylock lives here rookie
bets I'm about to say I don't even know
what that is oh yeah mookie bets Kirk
Herbstreit Lucia right here she lives
here I believe so oh a lot of announcers
live here oh really country music
Starship I'm assuming they're all pretty
rich I don't know what scale yeah I
think some a lot of them do pretty well
um yeah I think there's a lot of
interesting cats that live out here
because it's kind of like now it's
becoming a lot more exposed everybody
knows now you know well the the reason I
say Reno is growing earlier is they said
the two fastest growing cities in
America are Reno and Nashville no way
yeah
you know and I will say this about Reno
it was beautiful
it's an hour away from
you're close you're close to Beauty tile
is beautiful but it was like set in the
mountain just kind of like Boise like 20
years ago like boys he was like Jesus
this place is unbelievable like there's
just nobody here yeah but Reno it's a
lot of just people walking from one AAA
meeting to the next a lot of butt stuff
going on yeah a lot of uh you know
people bumming cigarette oh like not
even Vapes they haven't heard of Vapes
you know like people still doing
cigarettes did you listen do you ever
listen to the guy Andrew huberman dude
we just asked him to come on really yeah
so he would he uh he just came out with
a podcast on nicotine and I just been
recently trying to get into nicotine
like I just been recently trying to
really what do you want to do once
you've got it once you what do you want
to do it just seems fun yeah it just
seems like something to do and it's it
feels like it's a good way to bond with
people oh yeah
um
but but I was I listened to his podcast
on and he just dropped a podcast on
nicotine but I was just Park Austin his
podcast and alcohol and it was so
depressing yeah
alcohol's not good for you at all
nothing about it there's not even a plus
yeah I was bummed I still am kind of
bummed about it it's making me like just
feel bad
well do you ever think that alcohol will
become a thing of the past like you know
there's a lot more people what kind of
bug is that damn I just one of those uh
let me see if I can get that [ __ ] fast
good luck you think it's bothering the
audio or no all right never mind
um do you think that like alcohol will
kind of fade out because mushrooms have
become a lot more popular see a lot of
people Milling around on mushrooms at
parties [ __ ] funerals whatever people
want to enhance the experience yeah you
know funeraling funeraling on mushrooms
now is a big thing yeah
um I don't know I think they're gonna
have to have a replacement for the likes
because even mushrooms is like it
sometimes do not have the the coolest
conversation of all time and by cool I
just mean like under control yeah
alcohol is like it's a nice social
lubricant like you can have a couple
drinks and like have a great
conversation you can do with your
parents you can do with your friends
like you might not want to have
mushrooms with your parents that's true
but if there's a replacement dude the
hangovers are are terrible and as I'm
getting older they get worse and worse
and I listen to this podcast and that in
the podcast he's like if you have one or
two drinks a week then like raises your
cortisol which I guess is like your you
feel anxiety levels and it's like even
so if you don't have it you just
automatically raising your your anxiety
just walking around all the time I
didn't feel like I had any anxiety
walking around all the time and now I'm
starting to think about it am I feeling
anxiety I had one or two drinks where I
have 45.
and so
I'm trying to like damn I think also the
word anxiety has started to be used for
like any type of feeling if people even
have a thought they're like oh [ __ ] yeah
that's how I'm feeling so now I'm trying
to get into nicotine get addicted to
that he has a new podcast on them like
this dude's trying to sabotage my life
I'm not listening to it yeah well you
already did man not the nicotine one
well yeah I think you just steer clear
from that probably especially if the
other one did that to you but I'm it's
interesting like people be like I'm
having anxiety about my schoolwork it's
like you haven't done your [ __ ]
schoolwork that's why I don't know
nothing about it yeah dude it's due in
seven hours and you're about to go to
sleep that's not anxiety you've [ __ ]
done your work
like that's the weird thing about the
word anxiety it's just getting really
really like kind of tossed around and
everything
um and that is true on a serious level
that is true it is yeah I think that
that's one thing it's really it's
pillaging like a lot of like
vocabularies and people getting on meds
um they said 70 of adults in America are
on one type of medication
what is it I'm not sure they didn't say
but then they said 30 are on two types
of medication
so just fascinating to think how much
meds are going into people dude I heard
a thing so my brain is just like I only
I listen to like a podcast and I hear
like one thing I don't remember which
podcast it was or who said it or if it's
true but then I'll just remember it they
said that Cialis actually makes you
smarter uh-uh like it helps you and it
makes you you don't have as much uh a
likelihood of getting uh what is it
called not AOS
um Alzheimer's oh wow see Alice if
you're a regular user of Cialis damn
I mean I I mean I've been I've used all
that [ __ ] over the years
dude I once went and lived with a man
because he had a prescription and I
could chirp half of his pills dude
to date bro that's pretty sad
um
uh I mean he was a straight man
everything but it was like I knew he had
him he was older and so I knew he had
that script so I go in there sneak and
like nibble a piece off the side of one
like hoping he wouldn't see it I'd get
like a little just a little nibble but
um dude I think one of the issue uh I
used to take those gas station ones you
know yeah those Rhino 600s or whatever
right and the ones that came out they
had a Camo Edition that came out for a
while and those [ __ ] man I remember
going to this girl's house one night in
Florida and I'm trying to engage in sex
and my nose just starts bleeding all
over her
just like straight out of my brain bro
like just ideas I had just flowed right
out onto this lady bruh God some of that
shit's bad for you
but I'm glad that they're making it
better dude know who really got screwed
Jewel the singer
Maybe
God I loved her the uh the nicotine like
industry tools Jewels Jewels Jewels I
was yeah they they got outlawed they got
banned yeah really like oh this is not
safe banned wow you can't make any more
there's one million one million other
Alternatives
and the guys I drew are like what the
[ __ ]
wonder what they did that was so bad huh
they must have pissed somebody off they
did part of the Manning family yeah yeah
probably so huh Donnie Jewel over there
um
I'm trying to think what else we can get
into oh so you got you got the bills
coming out of the AFC who do you have
coming out of the NFC NFC
uh
Packers
I think Rogers gets it figured out yeah
dude he is like
he's so good even they lose he looks so
good all he has to do is get a couple
dudes to like figure out what he's doing
hmm
because you really want a quarterback
and I guess like playoffs who cares
about the regular season when you get to
the playoffs you want a quarterback
right who's cool and who can make it
happen when it matters yeah rarely does
somebody go somebody rarely wins without
a quarterback I almost put I almost put
a Futures bet on on uh on the Packers on
the barcel sports book I was like I was
gonna put like a bunch of money on them
to win the Super Bowl and then uh
and then I I realized the odds were kept
going they kept on changing like I was
going to lose money it's like this
Tennessee game we're going to I bought
tickets they're so expensive now
Tennessee's undefeated I'm trying to
sell them again they're caught they're
going for less than when I bought them
I'm like they're undefeated really yeah
you can lose money trying to make future
decisions like that my investments have
always been bad oh I made a lot of poor
Investments man not even bad it's just
like every time I play the stock market
crypto all I just lose it's like how do
I just do it just I'm like does this
just happen to everybody and we're
always being duped I think it does
that's what I feel like I feel like we
all get duped pretty easy I bought I
still last time I was on the podcast you
may feel me for Bitcoin we talked about
it I still buy a Bitcoin every day every
single day I buy Bitcoin every day it
just goes down every day either way
it could go either way for you
um and even it goes up I'm never gonna
sell it so it's just gonna I'm just
paying I don't know it makes no sense
yeah sometimes it's just like we get
caught into wanting to be a part of like
the game or whatever is going on and it
doesn't seem real also when you do stuff
on your phone it should it doesn't seem
real yeah it doesn't it seemed like kind
of fictional stuff you know it's selling
like I don't know if you've ever sold
something like that like sold a stock or
sold crypto like super stressful and you
got to pay so much tax I just don't do
it so I just buy the stuff
is kissing money goodbye dude
I'm I'm a poor poor I was gonna say with
money but just poor yeah
are you saving up now do you think do
you think that Nashville is going to be
a place that you'll come back to what
does that look like for you do you think
I'm trying to give it so I'm gonna be
here until February for sure okay and
I'm gonna give it that amount of time to
like basically feel feel it out and it's
growing on me too like the more I'm here
the more I think I understand it I
understand the appeal of it oh yeah if
you come to Nashville the first weekend
you go you're going Broadway
and if you have someone come in they're
going to want you to go to Broadway
right so it takes longer to like expand
outside of that little strip to see like
what's really going on here why do
people like it but I think the reason
why people like is I think it's super
accessible yeah in terms of
people like even like high profile
people would ever come down here like
models will come here but they're not if
you go to Miami you got to dress up you
got to be seen you got to look cool you
got to be going the right place the
right people here it doesn't matter the
type of person that comes everyone can
go everywhere yeah you can wear whatever
yeah that is true that yeah I think
that's something nice about it feels
comfortable things feel very accessible
here yeah like my buddy invited me to a
concert when I was going to see Black
Crowes he's like you want to go I was
like sure I'll go in 12 minutes I was
parked and we were walking across the
street yeah into the uh Amphitheater you
know it's like things are really really
accessible
um honestly my biggest worry about
Nashville is just about how how popular
it's getting and how many people like it
so I'm like if I do because I'm looking
like buy somewhere like try to even just
settle down even if I don't buy like
settle down in one spot yeah for more
than six months because I've been pretty
much doing six months here six months
there and Nashville's gonna be so
different in like five years ten years I
know everywhere changes but the rate the
National's changing is like you might
sign up for something but you don't
necessarily know what you're going to
get
well it's one of the last cities in the
South that is um growing really a lot of
cities have experienced a lot of issues
um and it's one of the last like kind of
Southern cities I feel like know our
love but they have no good airport or
else I would think about going there
Mobile Alabama oh really you've been
there yeah that's a nice city that's a
very very Southern nice city I stopped
over there and saw a buddy of mine
in recovery on Thanksgiving you were
both crying in this [ __ ] yard [ __ ]
was insane but
um yeah I like it down there I got uh
half sister that lives over there in uh
Spanish Fort
yeah it's nice down there it's almost
like they're pretending like it's
Florida but it's [ __ ] Alabama yeah
it's I I really think it has like a
charm to it kind of feels like
Charleston a little bit oh it does
downtown they really made it nice yeah I
think as as more development goes on
over there because it's gotten real busy
in that area
um
what happened with the golf
uh with the golf
basically I realized so my whole thing
was like and I was dead serious about
people thought I was messing around and
it was
yeah I knew it was funny to say
something what was it I was my first
round I was 51 Strokes over par okay so
if like par 72 I was like 121. and so I
was like
over the next lifetime I'm gonna get
Shay 51 Strokes off be a scratch golfer
and then from there my dream is to go
pro on some level I mean it doesn't be
PGA tour at the time live wasn't a thing
but if it's still a dream it's still a
dream but I'm not doing working towards
it okay yeah
which is literally the definition of a
dream
but the reason is because I love what I
do so much like I love working at
Barstool so much I love traveling around
making my videos I realize maybe this is
attainable in terms of if I really did
and I have different resources than
everyone else probably has if they're
trying to go after this like I knew
people who were like the top Chris Como
who's like Tiger Woods Golf coach yeah
was like working with me wow but because
of Barstool and just good networking and
like I had something to offer him too
and of of a platform so
I had I was sponsored by uh TaylorMade
and G4 like G4 is my clothing sponsor
and Taylor Made was my club sponsor so
you were all ready to be on the tour I
was honestly I did make it I was Pro
because I was getting paid to be sucky
yeah but um so I had like way more
resources so if I think and I have like
a
I'm not a great athlete but I'm like a
good enough athlete where I think I'm
I'm past a threshold of what you have to
be to be a professional golfer
and I do think I have the mind for it
but I realize you have to do this every
single day and you can't I couldn't make
videos traveled done any stuff I love to
do that the lifestyle that I worked so
hard to get to I worked so hard to get
to the lifestyle that I love and I was
gonna have to just like cancel it out to
just play golf every day and I was like
it's not it's not worth it to me I'd
rather just be a dream
well it's it's interesting because
you're kind of living one dream yeah
it's hard to dream jump
that's kind of what I realized and it
sounds so obvious but I was like dude
I'm already living a dream why am I
going to cancel out something no I
already had to go from I might not get I
could break my back and just have that
neither thing
yeah dude oh that'd be the worst bro if
you were do they have any wheelchair
guys on the PGA tour they have a dude
who is he's on the PGA but his name is
Jake Olson he played Long Snapper at USC
Southern Cal and he's blind oh wow and
bro he is I think he's like a I want to
say he's like a seven handicap like he's
like
he's amazing at golf he plays with his
dad his dad goes out there puts the ball
down oh tells him how many yards it is
lines him up to the to the shot and he
smacks it damn I might have lied about
his handicap he is technically
handicapped though yeah
but dude he's and he's an awesome guy
and that that's an accomplishment bro
people are like hey what's your handicap
handicapped I'm blind yeah all of it
yeah
dude a friend of mine took a picture one
time with OJ and they like snuck a knife
out and held it up like while they were
taking the oh no that's not what
happened a friend of mine a friend of
mine took a picture with O.J Simpson one
time and they sent it to me and it was
like they were holding up like a black
glove like they got on the outside of
the picture
and I always look at that you should get
him on this show
I've thought about it man
there's definitely some unique guests
that we would like to have on you know
um I've always liked how you pick people
who are like interesting people not
necessarily like the like the biggest I
mean you have the biggest stars on but
then I feel like you go for the people
who are like interesting
yeah I go for what's kind of just in my
what feels fun to me right now who am I
like who's popped into my radar in my
little world and would be kind of
interesting to talk to I've realized
that some kind of guess I'm not that
great at talking to
um but uh who's your white whale ooh
that white whale
you know I would really like to have
Macklemore on I think would be cool yeah
why
um I just I'm just intrigued by him you
know I'm just intrigued by his kind of
his journey he's been through like dealt
with like sobriety and stuff like that
sometimes that kind of stuff's
interesting because people are battling
their own demons you know uh he's a golf
guy too is he huge oh wow that's cool
he's like a golf line I was a huge fan
of I mean who wasn't yeah you couldn't
yeah look at us yeah I was a huge fan oh
I can dance again
[Laughter]
um so I get I mean obviously there's
some other people I think Kevin Spacey I
think will be real interesting
um is he in jail
no he's in Europe I think uh Michael
Landon deceased
uh who else man
who else is some real oh uh Jared Leto I
think would be nice he would be good yup
Nate Diaz
um
[Music]
yeah what about yourself man because you
got some you got some real hitters on
Kodak Black that was so wild he should
you would love Kodak really oh yeah is
he a real nice guy yeah but so our
interview was at 3 15 a.m uh p.m yeah in
the afternoon and at Pompano where he
lives and we shot the interview at 12 30
at night hey
it was fine it was like hey this is what
we signed up for hey Kodak Black
yeah I mean it's like I did I was not
living by this white clock
he's great you love him he's awesome
yeah he seems Relentless oh I want my
white whale right now is I kind of have
two mine is uh
you know the guy who's be on the Howard
Stern Show uh Beetlejuice yeah he's a
white whale for me oh he seems great I
saw a cool clip of him the other day he
just doesn't do he doesn't uh he lays
low he's alive but he lays low is he he
must have a liver issue huh I know he's
on dialysis I don't know what uh that
could be lever I don't know what that's
for I think diabetic right
I don't know something I don't know
either I don't even know if I was
supposed to say that but yeah
um and James Winston is my he's probably
my more obtainable I would love to have
James on oh that'd be cool he's got a
lot of thoughts yeah dude I think he'd
be perfect for your show actually he
just because his eyes seem real creative
like you don't know what's going on
sometimes there's something going on in
there yeah yeah yeah so I think that
that would be pretty tight
yeah it's interesting and it all you
know I'd love to have Boosie again I
think would be fun Boosie would be cool
with you guys too yeah I mean I feel
fortunate like yeah it's fun to just
kind of get us to sit and chat with
folks dude we got to go um
when we're over at Jimmy John's that uh
we got asked to go hunting yes
um with Michael Waddell
who's like the goat of hunting right
yeah he's a real Woodsman I believe you
know from what I've seen
yeah what happened with Brett Favre if
he did that
he's looking bad for him I'll tell you
this I walked into a I'll tell you this
I walked into a restaurant one time
Brett Favre was sitting in there eating
with his family I think
and
I didn't say anything to him
some people wanted to take pictures with
him but he kind of like asked them if
they would take him from far away just
with him sitting in the background
eating
which seemed insane bro
so there was like a string of like five
kind of like women you know or you know
like people with tits I don't know what
to call them nowadays yeah right but and
they were just all kind of smiling just
sitting there just eating shrimp at this
table dude
so it's an insane ask so what I'm saying
is I think he stole the 5 million
I mean that's facts here you go Michael
Waddell right there and he killed
something right there what is that a
damn Doberman what I can't see that
that's a deer I'm excited dude I'm
actually nervous that I'm I'm a little
nervous that uh I'm nurse that I won't
like it because I've never been before
I've done like I mean I've shot guns and
stuff like that and I actually went out
one time and tried to kill a deer and
didn't and uh
I'm nervous that I will get out there
because so many people I love love it
and I want to be a part of it it seems
like such a fun activity to do and such
a good hobby yeah as you get older did
you need more Hobbies yeah I got to get
some good Hobbies man I think I'm a
little bit nervous like I wish we had to
fight the animal
with a knife for me I feel like then it
seems more fair you can do that with
pigs I think yeah but even then I think
they somebody kind of holds them and you
run up and stab a machine like Jesus
dude what's different about that than
killing with a gun from like five five
meters away but this seems even like
[ __ ] more Italian or something like
why are we doing this man that's just
sausage bro well yeah but I don't know
it's like there's two guys you barely
know they're [ __ ] [ __ ] you just run
up and shank them but that's what I like
for hunting is like I do feel a part of
me I want to be a part of the adventure
and I want to love it but I would be
lying if I said there wasn't part of me
it's like I have a gun
I got a gun yeah I'm gonna win this
what's the challenge
but I know there is one I just don't
understand it fully and I'm excited for
Michael to teach us about it yeah and I
think he said there's different options
of things that we could shoot you know
or things that we could trap or kill I
wouldn't mind setting something up you
strangle something a duck you know which
seems like it'd be easy to catch in like
uh dude well I was living in Florida you
can kill the iguanas oh wow if you want
you can you can hunt the iguanas in your
backyard
and and uh snakes and
pretty much I think forward pretty much
anything really you want yeah oh wow and
what can you are you like when you can
just go do it whenever
yeah oh wow you're supposed to because
they're overgrown
they're having so much now it's [ __ ]
just every regular somebody works at
Chase Bank it's his [ __ ]
responsibility I guess dude because
they're just going everywhere
so now this dude's buying a bow and
arrow he's just driving around at night
because the city's telling him to bro
I'm telling you the government is full
it is falling apart a piece at a time
and it's getting it we're all
everybody's doing the they got dogs
hunting drugs now like it's all [ __ ]
falling apart man
it's not going to end well dude it's not
going to end well I don't know
yeah you might be right man who do you
want to hunt the drugs
no I don't care what the dogs do that's
true yeah and they probably got cloud
and [ __ ] amongst other dogs dude I was
in uh
you know muffin found a gram
I was I was in so I was part of a dog
fight okay and one of my friends has a
big pit bull
wait we cut that AC on real quick
brother thank you man one of my friends
has this big pit bull and he got into a
fight I won't name names my friend would
be embarrassed but his his dog
attacked another dog on the side of the
street and was getting walked was in
Boca Raton so his dog attacked another
dog on the side of the street and this
this other dog is getting walked by old
it's Boca so you can imagine what the
lady's looking like and uh and it's just
tearing this dog up and I'm supposed to
be watching he's working out I'm
supposed to be watching this dog and I'm
in the pool
[Laughter]
oh my God hop out the pool go out there
it's tearing this little dog apart and
this lady screaming
so and that's a whole it's a long story
anyways I had to I had to pick up I had
to pull the pit bull off this other dog
I think it was a golden doodle I had to
pick it up and I and I got it off but
soon as it landed it jumped up and that
dog bit me and walked into my arm the
little one the little one and it was
because it was scared and it wouldn't
like uh for it felt like 30 seconds but
it was probably one second so I had to
go to the hospital everything so I got
it all figured out
the next week
the next week I'm going through the
Charleston Airport and I got a long
flight back to New York this is a while
ago and I had taken a little bit of an
edible of weed baby huh and so just for
nothing crazy but yeah just to get home
yeah and uh
and I was as soon as I got the airport I
probably took it like 30 minutes before
I got the airport as soon as I get the
airport I'm like kind of I'm like
feeling it you know I'm just I'm a
little aware of everything that's going
on and not at the same time yeah
and this this police officer walks up to
me as I'm going through TSA and he said
Hey Brother come here and I said oh man
I was like what's this going to be he's
like hey
um
we have these these uh bomb dogs out
here and we're testing them
and we need we need you to walk through
TSA we're going to give you this little
uh it was like a little packet is that
you just put in your pocket and it
smells like a bomb
he's like just walk through TSA like
you're normal and just we're gonna see
if the dogs notice
he's a kite
I just got attacked by a dog the week
before
finally it's my time it's it's my time
to go through the thing and I'm looking
at the dogs I'm looking around
and by the way they didn't tell other
people in TSA line oh because it's a
long TSA line with a hundred other
people yeah that's miscommunication it
and so I walked through and of course
jumping up on me I'm losing my mind I'm
freaking out the whole Airport's looking
this guy's got a bomb
foreign
I made it out of life but
yeah I don't and I don't I don't mess
with dogs like that anymore yeah in
terms of breaking up their fights if
they're gonna fight
best man wins yeah somebody else that's
got you know that's God or nature like
nature does all kind of [ __ ] that we try
to stop a lot of times that's insane
flooding dog fights it's like you got to
think like but it flood yeah now she's
doing it we're like we'll build this
little wall they should be like [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] out of your mind
um I remember one time they had uh
um oh [ __ ] I think it was about an
animal but I forgot oh well
um
yeah I think we might have covered maybe
everything Caleb is there anything else
we didn't cover really no dude oh we
want to go hunting
we're supposed to go with Michael
Waddell
yeah and I'm really sad about it I mean
I don't have you hunted a lot I don't
know you seem like you would be someone
who hunted a lot but I don't think you
have and I'm wearing this today too yeah
before hunting
so I have I wouldn't say I've hunted I
did a lot of peeping tommen and stuff
and I was like when I was real young you
know
um
I have been on I used to shoot snakes I
used to work on this farm and we would
shoot snakes all afternoon uh with like
handguns and stuff but
I wouldn't say I've hunted you know
trying to think of anything else that
I've oh my brother and I shot a dove
last week
um
and I've had recently my brother cook
some raccoon
and we did have some squirrel as well so
you haven't hunted this what I'm taking
from this yeah yeah yeah I guess I have
it it'll be fine for both of our first
times that's true huh yeah first time
hunting I mean it's a good guide to go
with oh you don't like it with him We're
not gonna like it that's true and he was
and he's awesome too he was at dude I
don't know what Jimmy is okay with us
saying and not but his that little group
he puts together yeah is such a eclectic
and awesome group of people for that
little trip it's like a summer trip I
don't know if you talked about on here
or not yeah I have talked about it yeah
we got to go to uh Jimmy John is a jack
Pine uh he does a summer camp every year
in Wisconsin and that's kind of where
you and I kind of got to kick it and
hang some yeah
um yeah and there's like music and just
good food macaroni
uh great people
you'll just be sitting around you'll
have there's like billionaires yeah not
just Jimmy but there's other like huge
dudes and then there's Michael Waddell
there's you there's guys are like Titans
of Industry then there's country singers
NASCAR drivers and then they're just
families normal people Emma lagosi's
there the emeralds there beef jerky
owner yeah was there beef jerkies and
then you're just kind of sitting around
you're hanging it just kind of like a
cool interesting Vibe yeah we played
some uh volleyball that was awesome
people played music caught some carp and
some Northern
what else man but I've heard it's well I
don't know I was up there the year
earlier yeah and it was [ __ ] bananas
dude yeah Vince Neil out there losing
his gills you know dude you had a kid
rock out there just him and Travis
Trevor throwing shoes at each other I
mean she was [ __ ] lit man yeah maybe
next should be like a happy medium
because I think this year was very
conservative it felt like it's my first
time yeah it was it was low-key everyone
was like telling stories about the years
past you should have seen
yeah he should have been there yeah it
was like being in high school like dude
with the last senior Blaster they were
crazy yeah that was always it huh did
y'all have a big senior thing that
happened at the end of the year like a
big like competition or anything like
that
I don't remember dude I don't have a
good memory yeah I don't either
I wonder what that is
I think dude I was like he'd been
podcasting could be drinking
yeah but it could be just we could be
naturally have bad memories
could have been cocaine for me I don't
know if cocaine does anything to your
brain or not
but feels like it could
football football's a good one yeah CT
there's a lot of ways to hurt your brain
but dude you're only here one time yeah
and you only need your brain tell you
about what 45 yeah probably 60. 60. a
little early dude I've always been bad
about that though I've always been like
dude when I'm dude when I'm 29. oh yeah
yeah but when you were a kid you see
somebody that's like 35 like this
[ __ ] easier yeah it's [ __ ] ancient
guy with this mustache yeah God just
like molest Me or Leave bro you [ __ ]
creeping everybody yeah iPad you don't
even care yeah I'm on my iPad Kayla
Presley you can uh check him out on
Sunday conversation and how often does
it come out so during this
Sonic conversation is a part of our
inept barcel NFL show okay it's a
segment okay so like the whole idea
behind it was
um like the NFL Countdown I think it's
that's what has is some they have Sunday
conversation got it which is a
one-on-one conversation it's like what's
our interview segment gonna be and then
a guy a bars named Rowan was like Sunday
conversation yeah which was have Lindy
balls eat some ice cream it'll be a
Sunday and so that's how it started and
then it's kind of took on of its life of
its own but it runs during football
season it's part of our football show so
every Sunday for football season every
Sunday oh okay I get it that's when it
comes out yeah man I'd eat I'd eat some
mushrooms before I went on mine with you
really yeah I was just not feeling good
man I needed something just to I was
just I've been just going through this
over a time period I just had been
feeling really like just like just
depleted yeah so nothing crazy it's one
of our highest viewed episodes of all
time oh really yeah oh that's awesome
man that's awesome yeah it was a lot of
fun I like being in there and seeing
Glenny in there and I love seeing him
you know that's why I always every guest
I'm like you met Glennie balls yet and
if they say no I'm like boy you're in
for it yeah it's just it's like it's
just such a uh he's gonna see that he
does and you don't see that in the wa
you don't see that in the wild
and his Legend's growing yeah or you
don't see that in captivity if that's
just something you see in the wild
yeah and in some ways I try to make sure
I don't I just let him you know let him
be yeah we go to a new city we went to
Tampa last week for Ric Flair and I knew
he's going to get there a couple days
early he's going to leave a couple days
late and he's going to be in Tampa for a
while he'll show up for a 15-minute
interview and he'll eat some ice cream
but he'll be in Tampa for a while yeah
man he's almost like a warm front yeah
can't control him when he's coming and
he don't know he's leaving you'll know
what he's going to do but you know some
people's gonna be wet
uh Kayla Presley man thanks so much for
your time dude I look forward we'll go
on our first hunt can't wait yeah well
the video we'll just shoot a little
video or something maybe that'll be
really fun I would like to do more stuff
in Nashville with you yeah it'd be fun
man me too bro thanks for being here
with us cool
[Music]
rolling like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life I found I
can feel
it in the bones
but it's gonna take